We have a voicemail number, which is two one
nine two David P..
The term cultural Marxism is one that is being
bandied about by some on the right recently.
That's exactly what today's voicemail deals
with.
Let's take a listen to it and then I'll tell
you about it.
Here we go.
Hey, David, this is Stephen from Virginia.
And I just wanted to talk to you about.
I've been seeing a lot of people throw around
the phrase cultural Marxism, and I don't know
if you know that or other people know that.
But that's kind of a call back to the conspiracy
of cultural Bolshevism from World War to the
Nazis.
And it's pretty anti-Semitic sort of dog whistle.
It is.
So anytime you hear someone talk about cultural
Marxism, it should be a red flag for you that.
Absolutely.
And cultural Marxism.
The cultural Marxism is presented by the right
as some kind of serious thinkers hypothesis,
it's really a conspiracy theory with some
significant anti-Semitic twists.
It's kind of like political correctness on
steroids.
And the idea is that the originators of cultural
Marxism who are often Jewish, when you look
at the theories, are secretly trying to subvert
the culture of the United States into a Marxist
culture.
So it's less about economic Marxism, but it's
the idea of often Jewish philosophers, sometimes
involving Columbia University, figuring out
a way to subvert American society and culture
with cultural Marxism rather than than economic
Marxism.
And it is it is bigoted.
It's quacky and wacky.
And so there's a lot of different flavors
where sometimes the perpetrators are black
people.
Sometimes it's LGBT folks.
Sometimes it's the left.
Often it's Jews.
And it should be a right when you hear cultural
Marxism.
It should indeed be a red flag.
And I'm glad that the caller is pointing it
out.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Don't miss it.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
join Pacman Skop.